by the way yes sir just an opinion
you should be dating kat bardo
my makeup lady your makeup lady
she's she's right over there you want me
to date my makeup lady no no i don't
want you to have sex with your makeup
lady that's where you eat i
want you to just take her out show her a
good time well now have dinner get her
liquored up take her back to her place
and be like thanks for the makeup and
walk out
that again once again that is
where you eat yeah i think you should
start a relationship and just start with
dinner and don't have any expectations
be a gentleman which you are yes and see
where it leads and just pray that one
day the show gets cancelled and we just
straight up plow each other
no no no no
you can plow each other if it becomes a
relationship i'm saying you don't oh you
don't want it to be a casual hookup
you're you're always people you work
with that's bad that's where
you eat yes okay but if you have a real
relationship and you fall in love
whatever it feels good whenever people
say and where you eat i just think
of how great it would be to have a
toilet right by your refrigerator
you're making a ham sandwich and you're
like
we know where this is going and we just
kind of
yeah but it doesn't move that quickly
there's the time that's why magazines
are far more important magazines are and
newspapers i can't go poo poo unless i
have
and do you know i've never said that
but i have said this i can't make a duty
unless i unless i have something you
have a pavlova a poop
even an ipad i need something and i poop
yeah but
you you and cat that's what i'm saying
you are so i'm feeling like i never had
a jewish mother but you're as close as i
can come
yeah
you're a fun time joe derosa writes on
your show he's hysterical should i date
him too no
unless you're a gay gentleman which i
don't i don't think you are i'm not i'm
not then he's not either therefore it'd
be very uncomfortable if you asked him
out on a date
and you went on a date and he'd say
where is this leading and you'd have to
say no where we're both straight men
yeah but we're in love
and we take a little ecstasy and watch
talented mr ripley and everything gets
blurred
i've never seen that movie it's a very
uh i have a friend who was sitting next
to a guy on the plane who watched that
movie and my friend had seen it and he
knew by the guy that the guy was going
to break out in hysterics at the end yes
and he did on the plane